JANET RANKIN: The
technique of debate
is a really interesting
and useful technique.
I make sure to arbitrarily
assign students
the side that they'll
be taking in the debate
because it's pretty
easy to debate something
you feel passionate about.
It's not so easy
to debate something
that you don't feel
passionate about,
or where you feel the
other side is correct.
In terms of learning, I
think it's a great exercise
because it forces people
to, at least superficially,
understand the stated arguments
for the side they're taking
and then find a
way to at least be
semi convincing about
those arguments.
And then I give them
a period of time
to prepare, to sort of
prepare their arguments
about how they're going
to defend their positions.
And then I have them
voice their arguments
for the particular side
that they've been assigned.
So in crafting the arguments,
pro if you're a con,
you really have to
start to understand
what goes behind those
arguments a little bit
better, and so that's where the
learning takes place I think.
The other thing is
that the students get
a little bit
competitive, so they want
to construct a good argument.
They want to sound convincing.
And so that extra little
bit means that they really
do put in the effort to
construct a good argument
and to make it believable.
If I were making recommendations
to someone who had never
used a debate before I would say
that you should, first of all,
don't pick anything that's
really emotional to start out
with.
So people can have a pretty
strong opinion about it,
but it's not something
that's really deep.
So I would stay away from
something too touchy.
The other thing
is that it should
be something where it's
really not a slam dunk one
way or the other.
So you want to make sure
that the topic that you
choose really does have
two reasonable positions.
You don't want to give one
team just a terrible thing
to have to argue.
The other thing you
want to make sure
is that you give students enough
time to craft their arguments
and to debate the points.
So that if you cut the debate
short after three minutes,
it's just not going to help.
So you have to set aside a
pretty good chunk of time.